there are plenty of tomatoes in the
northern Nigerian state of Cano and soon
these farmers won't have to carry their
products to the market anymore they'll
be able to sell directly to this do
tomato paste Factory this plan will pull
that magic plan it is a la morra
plan and this plan will take the 120
stock that is a drink for hours they
will operate in English sixty people
will be in a monic system and sixty
people will be in a night shift the
plant is being built by billionaire
elico dangoty Africa's richest man then
goatee made his billions in cement sugar
and flour but he's been increasingly
investing in agriculture in his homeland
his goal is to end Nigerian dependence
on food imports for example up to now
Nigeria has imported tomato paste from
China Italy and the US when this factory
gets into full operation imports will no
longer be needed within the next two
years
Asia Nigeria is self-sufficient in
tomato paste how to import market based
but looking forward to win an export of
tomato paste
so that is a long-term vision the
factory has the capacity to process the
harvest from fifty thousand farmers it's
a local dango days contribution to the
region's development the billionaire was
born nearby
you